Times feel rough - with natural disasters,
major political conflicts and uncertainty
about the future.
But as the memes roll in about it being a
horrible time to be alive, you might be surprised
to see your life now vs what it would have
been in the past.
Much of history actually involves humans succumbing
to malnutrition and hunger.
In Ancient Egypt, a severe drought could hit
and 5-10% of the entire population would die.
Of course, things aren’t perfect today with
11% of even France suffering from food insecurity
- which means their diet is limited due to
socio-economic status and they eat less nutritious
foods and excess amounts of carbohydrates
and salt - but compare this to the years of
1692-1694 when 15% of France’s population
literally died because food was simply too
expensive.
Today, while millions do suffer from malnutrition,
advancements in technology, government agencies
and NGOs help to ensure that most are not
dying.
In fact, for the first time in human history,
more people are overweight than suffering
from malnutrition.
As homo sapiens began to live in cities, there
was a massive increase in disease.
In the 1330’s a horrifying outbreak of what
they believed were demons, bad air or angry
gods killed 75-200 million people.
We now realize it was the flea dwelling bacterium
Yersinia Pestis, known historically as the
black plague.
But at the time, people really had no idea
what was killing them.
In 1520 a spanish flotilla heading to Mexico
had an individual on it, carrying an early
case of smallpox virus.
Within 2 months, the disease had killed 1/3rd
of Mexico’ population.
In the years following, there were so many
infectious disease outbreaks in Mexico, that
the population fell from 22 million to 2 million
over the course of only 60 years.
People were constantly dying of diseases and
nobody knew how to cure them.
Remedies at the time included praying, having
cold baths, or rubbing black beetles on sores.
Even as recently as 1918, the Spanish Flu
spread internationally and within a few months
1/3rd of the entire world population was infected,
and 3-5% of the world died.
Today, most of our flu worries are based around
the pain of needles.
Modern medicine saves millions of lives.
The smallpox vaccine fully eradicated the
disease from our planet.
When diseases like SARS or Ebola appear and
the world prepares for a severe public health
emergency, far fewer people die due to international
organization, modern technology and continued
advancements in medicine.
When Europe colonized the Americas, an estimated
100 million people died, though pre-colonization
populations of indigenous people is not well
documented making some estimates millions
higher.
As many as 85 million people died in WWII
and in ancient agricultural societies, human
violence caused 15% of all deaths.
Today, human violence accounts for around
1% of deaths.
In 2012, only 120,000 died in war, whereas
1.5 million died of diabetes.
For the first time in human history when most
people consider the future, they don’t assume
war.
As we look to this year, while there is still
starvation, disease, war and inequalities,
it is drastically better than most of human
history.
But we must continue to be critical of our
government’s, challenge companies and rethink
the way human society is structured in order
to continue progress.
By acknowledging the successful human efforts
in medical research, economic reform, peace
initiatives and governmental support to decrease
starvation, disease and violence, we can find
hope for the future.
Hope is a valuable notion to focus on as we
look for a way to be content in a world that,
at times, can seem so overwhelmingly bad.
If you could use a little light hearted fun,
check out our latest T-shirt “The rotation
of the earth makes my day” which we just
launched and is available for the next 2 weeks
only at asapscience.com/merch.
We really appreciate all your support through
the years, and couldn’t make these videos
without you!
If you like our stuff, be sure to give it
a like, comment, subscribe, and hit that bell
button - it all helps keep our channel going
in the YouTube algorithm, and means a lot
to us.